[Música]
quantas vezes você deixou de dar um
mergulho no mar porque você tinha
vergonha de mostrar seu corpo
quantas vezes você deixou de falar
coisas lindas histórias lindas suas por
medo de ser julgado rejeitada
quantos anos você perder a sua vida
trabalhando com uma coisa que você não
gosta porque não era isso que esperavam
de você
acho que todo mundo tem um sentimento
secreto de que não é bom o bastante e
que o impostor e uma farsa fazendo o que
faz e sendo quem é que a qualquer
momento pode ser descoberto
parece que as pessoas se sentem um pouco
perdida se o mundo cobra muita gente que
a gente seja certo que a gente tenha
todas as certezas sobre as decisões do
mundo que a gente honra a expectativa
dos outros início a gente gera uma
insegurança de ser e perde a vontade de
mostrar quem realmente é e assim não
demonstrar nossas angústias não
demonstra nossos medos esse fecho em
concha
essas pessoas têm medo de demonstrar
fraqueza tem medo de mostrar que são
sentimentais e assim se faz um universo
totalmente delas se sentem rejeitadas
perdidas em compreendidas e se sentem
anormais um mundo cheio de gente normal
mas será que essas pessoas são tão
normais assim eu trabalho com meu
trabalho de escritor e palestrante
eu sempre converso com muita gente eu
escuto muitas histórias e eu já me
sentia assim compreendido perdido
justiçado um pouco solitário mas será
que as pessoas se admitem ser assim
será que a gente não é maioria só que
ninguém confessa
o pensamento é mais ou menos assim
existe um jeito certo de agir e eu não
agi dessa forma então vou me camuflar
adaptar todo mundo pra cá eu vou indo
pra cá também
assim não vou gerar conflito ou namorar
alguém que não é a pessoa melhor pra mim
mas até aqui era legal
vou trabalhar uma coisa que não tem nada
a ver comigo mas dizem que um dia vai
dar dinheiro
sempre corri atrás de alguma coisa que
eu nem sei se eu quero mas está todo
mundo fazendo e não é assim que funciona
só que isso vai gerando na gente uma
angústia a nossa verdade um dia vai
querer sair a gente vai querer ver o que
a gente acredita que a gente sonha
isso vai girando na gente combustion vai
gerando a gente com o aperto que
acontece é difícil realmente demonstrou
que a gente é
todas as peculiaridades com todos os
defeitos com todos os medos com tudo que
a gente é de verdade
acontece que todo mundo mesmo carrossel
talvez o problema central mude mas a
música é a mesma
você não tá pronto você não é bom o
suficiente você na rica inteligente você
não é tudo que o mundo espera por um dia
realmente ser feliz
só que enquanto a gente não quebrar esse
ciclo enquanto a gente não entender que
a gente tem que sair disse que não leva
a lugar nenhum a gente nunca vai
conseguir ter conexões verdadeiras com
as pessoas e as pessoas com medo da
rejeição acabam se privando e quando
digo às pessoas falam de mim também
quando eu era criança é eu nunca me
senti muito adequado assim eu me senti
um pouco perdido e meus pais separaram
tinha sete anos e meu pai faleceu tinha
13 e 14 anos
eu sempre me senti adequado porque era
um pouco gordinho porque eu era tímido e
porque eu era estrábico que eu acho
lindo eufemismo para o mesmo e eu sempre
fiquei um pouco deslocado não conseguiu
olhar nos olhos das pessoas porque eu
sempre olhar vai ficar pensando que a
pessoa olhar de volta falou assim nossa
coitado quantos graus ele usa e
mentalmente eu responderia 6 mas eu
também eu juro
isso ficava olhando eu me senti um
pouquinho perdido e quando eu tinha ali
meus sete anos que os pais separaram ea
mãe saiu de são paulo e foi morar comigo
em blumenau meu pai continua em são
paulo
eu perdi tudo que tinha de seguro de
ativos amigos da menina que gostava a o
caminho que até o colégio contato da
minha segurança meu pai juntos e depois
eu fui pro colégio comecei a tentar
fazer amizades e não conseguiu os grupos
já estão formados é um pouco difícil até
que eu tive uma excelente ideia
eu falei ou escrevi uma carta para o
menino estava sentado ao meu lado
pedindo o seu amigo dele tem um papel
escrever que é meu amigo e deixar a
carteira
fomos para o intervalo é eu fiquei assim
essa idéia genial
ninguém vai recusar a amizade eu fiquei
pensando eu estava tão feliz tão alegre
com essa situação que eu nem pensava na
possibilidade de ele dizer não eu vou
ter toda a minha alegria
na mão daquela pessoa esperando que ela
fosse me devolver essa alegria
isso aconteceu a resposta não veio no
final do dia
nem no final da semana o final do ano
ele simplesmente ignorou e eu fiquei mal
mas pensando bem mal 17 anos mauá eo
triste naquela situação além de me
sentir inadequado porque eu já me sentia
me senti excluído porque não tinha feito
amizade eu também não me sentir
rejeitado
e aí eu percebi depois de um tempo que
tem uma coisa pior do que a dor da
rejeição é um medo da rejeição quando
tinha rejeitado uma vez a gente sente
que tudo pode acontecer de novo a gente
generaliza-se trauma e fala assim a
pessoa que rejeitou então vamos proteger
para isso não acontecer de novo porque
não quero que se repita essa rejeição e
aí a gente tem duas maneiras de fazer
isso
a estratégia da concha do camaleão da
coxa se oculta dentro de uma concha para
se proteger do mundo
só que quando a gente se oculta do mundo
a gente escuta nossas melhores partes
também esse é o tipo de pessoa que
provavelmente não vai selecionar muito
não vai dar muita opinião vai ficar
sempre quietinho no canto fazendo assim
não preciso ter conflito que ninguém
eu não vou me relacionar eu não vou
viver grandes alegrias mas eu também não
vê grandes decepções
então a pessoa ali protegida já o
camaleão você tende a se adaptar
você se adapta o que está acontecendo
como eu disse tá todo mundo pra lá vamos
pra lá vou me home pasteurizar vou me
colocar à normalidade para enfrentar
conflitos de eu sou diferente de todo
mundo então se meu irmão faz assim e
todo mundo gosta dele acho que você é um
pouco parecido com ele
esse é o tipo de pessoa que promete vai
relacionar com alguém que os pais
gostaria que vai ter uma faculdade que
todo mundo diz que é legal e não vai
conseguir ver a verdade que tem dentro
dela e não vivendo a verdade dentro dela
cada vez mais seguem angústia segue
frustrado e segue apertada consigo mesmo
a palavra vulnerabilidade vem divulgando
sede ferida
e quando a gente tem uma ferida a gente
realmente fica vulnerável o nosso
interno nosso sensível fica exposto ao
mundo
só com medo de cair de bicicleta não
pode ser maior que a alegria de sair
correndo pegar um vento pedalar com os
amigos se divertir ver uma paisagem
prazer da bicicleta tem que ser muito
maior do que o medo de cair de bicicleta
e isso pode acontecer com os outros
também
nem sempre os outros rejeitaram a gente
às vezes antes do outro rejeitar a gente
já se rejeita antes quando maneira carta
pro menino não pensei que talvez ele
pudesse não teria direito o que ele
tivesse vergonha de responder não
soubesse responder eu pensei eu não sou
um bom amigo eu não vou conseguir me
relacionar com ele outras pessoas se ele
rejeitou porque os outros não
rejeitariam quando a gente se relaciona
e convido alguém pra sair pra jantar ea
pessoa diz não a gente não pensar que
talvez a pessoa tem outras coisas pra
fazer seja uma fase ruim tenha terminado
o relacionamento agora não eu não sou
uma boa companhia eu não sou atraente o
suficiente
quando a gente vai a uma loja não tem
uma roupa do nosso tamanho a gente pensa
é preciso emagrecer e não que talvez a
loja que não tem todo tipo todo o tipo
de roupa até às vezes quando a gente
cozinha a gente vai lá e antes do começo
eu sei que está ruim mas assim qualquer
coisa então se antes o outro legal já tô
me defendendo já tô sendo aberto que eu
estou sentindo
e assim a gente vai dias após dias nos
ajeitando um pouquinho deixando de ser o
que a gente é pra tentar aceitar essa
normalidade ea gente sempre esperando a
aceitação de alguém não entende que
talvez a gente possa inverter esse papel
e provocar a aceitação de alguém isso
comigo aconteceu quando eu estava no
colégio estava com 13 para 14 anos
nessa época meu pai tinha falecido
também triste com a situação estava meio
perdido foi não tem um pai pra conversar
não tenha muito amigo quem eu sou nesse
universo eu falei preciso tentar fazer
outras amizades e perdeu um pouco da sua
timidez
eu ia caminhando todo dia até o colégio
e atravessava uma ponte com um risinho
através do caminho o chininha todo dia e
colégio e voltava de um dia eu pensei em
me propus um silencioso no é um
silencioso desafio e eu pensei assim
todo dia que foi o colégio uma vez por
dia
eu vou sorrir pra alguém na ponte e vou
ver o que acontece
só isso vou lá a sorrir para pessoa vou
embora e acabou no começo não conseguia
pessoa para pessoa
eu sentia que ela ficava meio assim eu
também olhava para baixo e tal
ficava com vergonha tem vez várias vezes
que eu nem conseguia sorrir professora e
até lá não sorrir pra ninguém fala
preciso voltar a sorrir
eu voltava até a ponte ficava em duas
três vezes até conseguir alguém depois
de um tempo sorrindo me provocando desta
forma eu percebi que as pessoas estão
começando a surgir de volta
naquele momento fiquei muito feliz eu
falei cara que legal eu sorrio para
alguém eu fico feliz porque é a pessoa
saindo de volta pra mim ela fica feliz
porque eu sorri pra ela que momento de
felicidade infinita entre duas pessoas
aumenta um pouco em cima dela lamentou a
mim a gente está feliz caminhando cada
um com seu destino
falei que momento legal isso me ensinou
tanto há como provocar para receber um
pouco mais a autoestima mas da mesma
forma de como ser mais vulnerável e
aprender que para ganhar um sorriso
muitas vezes eu tenho que dar o primeiro
sorriso eu tenho que me abrir às vezes a
gente quer que o outro se dói por
inteiro mas a gente só quer doar metade
da gente então é sempre uma forma
injusta
então até que ponto vale a pena vocês e
de teus sonhos cedeu o que você acredita
que a coisa mais importante que você tem
familiares em prol de terceiros ou de
estranhos e ver o que a gente tem de
mais verdade que a gente acredita que a
gente acha que a gente quer só para
suprir a expectativa de outras pessoas
sempre uma coisa injusta com a gente é
sempre uma coisa injusta com que a gente
acredita
até porque a gente sempre vai desapontar
alguém quando a gente saiu nossos sonhos
eu sempre digo que se você quer
conquistar o seu mundo você tem que
perder um pouco do seu mundinho eo teu
mundo o seu mundo interno do mundo
externo do trabalho a gente tem que
dizer adeus às vezes mesmo quando o amor
para poder seguir um caminho que a gente
acredita e por mais triste que seja esse
é o preço da liberdade do que a gente
quer sair do que a gente sonha eu
demorei pra aprender que tem pessoas que
não vão gostar da gente e tudo bem
talvez as pessoas
não admitam que a gente erre critiquem a
gente isso ou aquilo e já que a gente
não tem como se defender não têm como se
proteger disso porque a gente não se
expõe e mostra que a gente é sair da
concha tirar madura e realmente entende
que para a gente ter conexões profundas
com todo mundo a gente tem que ser abrir
porque o que protege a gente do exterior
é a mesma coisa que impossibilita a
gente de acessar ele então se a gente
não se abrir e for sincero o que a gente
sente
qual o sentido dessa vida a gente guarda
tanta coisa
se tem uma coisa que a gente não pode
guardar e afeto gente tem que falar o
que a gente sente no momento que a gente
tá vivendo dividir que a gente tá
mandando que é verdadeiro que a coisa
especial
não dá pra dizer não depois o amor é o
sentimento o que você sente que você é
as pessoas muitas vezes não sabem mais o
que realmente conecta as pessoas são as
imperfeições e não as perfeições eu
demonstrar que eu tô triste que eu tô
feliz eu posso me conectar com você
nesse momento falando contigo com vocês
me abrindo alguém possa identificar isso
gera uma conexão verdadeira isso é o
mais bonito da vida uma possibilidade de
encontro é encontrar quem a gente ama o
que a gente gosta de fazer então no meio
de tudo isso a gente tem que entender
que a gente não é perfeito ea gente não
precisa ser perfeita pra ser feliz
entender que o autoconhecimento é a
única maneira para você ter uma alta
aceitação quando você se aceita o mundo
te aceita e assim a vida vai seguindo
realmente dá medo de se abrir
dá medo de ser o que a gente é muitas
vezes mas no fundo quando tudo isso
apertar a gente tem que fazer uma
pergunta às pessoas que você mais ama
por acaso são perfeitas
obrigada
[Aplausos]